one of our viewers has completely cocked
alex jones this is the best we have
bumper stickers here at the David Pakman
show
and I recently got an email from Ryan
who's been a member for a couple of
years already and he wrote to me and he
said David every day driving to work I
have to stop right next to a transformer
like an electrical transformer that has
been branded with an info wars bumper
sticker since you clearly understand the
insanity of Alex Jones and Infowars I
wondered if you would send me a david
pakman show bumper-sticker
on the promise that it would be used to
cover up the atrocity that is this
Infowars
sticker i've been a member in daily
listener for around two years now and i
would much rather see your Staker when i
drive to work ryan asked and i delivered
so he sent his pictures this was my
condition you got to send his pictures
of this thing ryan sent to me and we're
putting up on the screen this is the
electrical transformer before ryan got
to it this is the view from the road and
then he also took a close-up of the
infowars.com sticker on this electrical
transformer and i present to you now
that same sticker covered up by a david
pakman show bumper-sticker and you can
see just the little last edge of the
Infowars bumper sticker and it has been
completely almost completely covered
yeah by the permanent marker would do
the rest
you could fill in that little white part
with permanent marker if you really were
committed to it and you can see it even
from across the street this is the best
he went back across the street and took
a picture of it and it's very clearly
the david pakman show logo the david
pakman show bumper-sticker
and here is ryan celebrating the
accomplishment with the bumper sticker
in the background this is a fantastic
job by ryan right I mean this is huge I
love it because the people that live in
that house are probably so confused as
to what's good they knew what Infowars
was but if they see that david pakman
show they're going to investigate I
wonder if the people in the house are
the people who put the Infowars bumper
sticker on the thing in the first place
yeah haven't there been stories about
matches
made in heaven where someone's like a
viewer was driving behind another viewer
who has a david pakman show
bumper-sticker there's been a couple
sightings each other
yep so someone in Newton Massachusetts
was once driving and they're fans of the
show and they saw another car driving
around with the david pakman show
bumper-sticker and then I believe in
Tennessee there was another one where I
remember viewers getting in touch one
viewer said hey I saw and I remember
what kind of car it was say it was you
know a Prius not to stereotype but maybe
it was a Prius or whatever I saw a Prius
with the david pakman show
bumper-sticker in this town and i
announced it and shortly thereafter
someone wrote in and they said oh yeah i
a drive a prius around in that town all
the time it's the same color car and I
have a david pakman show bumper-sticker
yeah I'm like I'd love it if in a few
months from now someone writes in saying
that I was driving down a road in
Rochester New York and i saw david
pakman show bumper-sticker on a
transformer did I I might have forgotten
to even say that this was Rochester New
York we allowed to say that no we are
yeah I just don't I don't know if I did
anyway Ryan you did it you cooked them
and what what else can I say
congratulations and with peace and love
let's do it again sometime somewhere
else get in touch if there are prominent
stickers you want to cover up in other
parts of the country